hey Kristen hi how's it going it's going
well how are you doing I'm doing great
now that's so nice of you we are gonna
be doing the season finale of worth
lifestyle today and I thought you would
be the perfect almost why is that well
we're doing engagement rings and
obviously you have Auto experience in
the marriage world I do I have been
proposed to and I am buried so I have
one experience and I have not much
experience in that world you seem very
nervous
which is why I watch I do this the right
way
Kristen share it go will you please come
on this video with me you have to
reschedule a lot of stuff yeah there we
go
today I'm one of the Lifesong we're
gonna be checking out three different
engagement rings at three drastically
different price points to find out which
one is the most worth its price worth it
for that we're gonna learn about
engagement rings today neither of us are
really shopping for this because you got
one half one already I don't got one but
I don't need one I feel like you're
gonna feel a little bit more comfortable
cuz right now you're kind of like and I
want you to get down to like a solid oh
I see okay okay yeah
my name is Cindy I'm the designer and
owner of ochre objects and we're taking
a look at my diamond ovate three-ring
collection is based around this one
shape that I'm really interested in
it's called ovate which is their
reference to like an egg or a leaf shape
and so I just play around with that
shape with different scales the
materials that I source are gonna be
different from what you would find at a
typical jewelry store because all of my
diamonds are reclaimed and recycled
which means that they either come out of
jewelry that already exists or they're
cut from the waste product of Diamond
linings I work with a casting shop that
uses recycled metal so they get their
gold from a refiner that takes gold from
the existing supply chain melt it down
alloys that there's no new mining of
fresh gold in the process and then all
of the colored stones that I use I try
to work with suppliers that use really
short supply chains and that know
exactly where the stones are coming from
just so that I can incorporate as much
transparency into my work as possible I
think it's more about connecting with
the person who makes it telling a story
with it knowing its history and have it
mean something rather than just a dollar
amount how much does this diamond ovate
3-ring cause the diamond of a 3-ring
costs 1065 1065 like that's a really
reasonable rate cost if them mean
something from that person to another
person yes it's like gift-giving it
literally is gift giving oh are you
ready to trying some rings oh you're
getting ready the Rings are coming off
oh it's so free so it has like this
really interesting detail work around
the diamond but if I put it on my ring
finger does that mean I'm engaged yes to
yourself okay
nice it's subtle but like you can tell
that like a lot of like thought and work
in beauty and artistry went into it
there's like these very subtle
engravings in the ring that are pointing
toward the diamond towards the dime yeah
so you know which part of the ring is
it's not what I expect to see on
somebody who isn't
were married mm-hmm but I like that
what's nice about this ring is that it's
not gonna get in your way it's gonna be
beautiful it's gonna hang out it's gonna
make your finger look sparkly but you're
not gonna keep hitting it on the car
door every time you get out this is
beautiful I'd like to see some of the
other rings to see what they look like
stackable all right so we have a bunch
of colored stones here
yes this is my birthstone for November
it's pretty why don't you put these on
see I mean this just feels like fun
dress up to me so there's the diamond
and then there's yours and pearls going
there oh that looks really nice yeah so
I figure kind of turning purple and I
was like maybe this is a bad idea
I have an idea what's your idea this is
what I hate I'm gonna put all these
brush stones in here shake it up choose
one and then that month will have to be
the person that I end up marrying oka
objects I think that Cindy really cares
about the craftsmanship and the
materials and where her rings come from
and honestly where they're going and I
think it's like that is a gift in and of
itself and is affordable it is afford I
really love that place I feel like it's
gonna be really hard for somebody to
beat that for me really a good deal
protip do not tell someone when you're
getting engaged to them but you've got a
good deal engage your impact oh it don't
cheat
I cannot never the average American
spends six thousand three hundred twenty
four dollars on engagement ring which
state spends the most of all the states
California yeah what are you
contributing to that price honestly my
engagement ring cost less than that Wow
average into California is nine thousand
Andrew nine dollars
I brought the average down all right
well this location that we're headed to
they are called competent worn what
trumpeter horn is actually where my
engagement ring came from what yes okay
we're not playing this
hi I'm Tommy hidin right and I'm Jerry
Heidenreich and we are at trumpet and
horn today and we're gonna be showing
you some fabulous vintage engagement
rings
so I heard you use the word vintage I
also heard the word antique be used
antique is a product over a hundred
years old vintage can literally be last
Thursday we sell things that are
generally 50 to 150 years old but more
than just vintage we like the
eco-friendly vintage if you buy
something vintage or antique there's no
new mining involved and new production
involved so there's no new greenhouse
gases going into the atmosphere
completely coincidentally this is
actually the place where my husband got
my engagement ring one thing about the
diamonds here is that a lot of them
because they're older they're not
necessarily cut to the way that we think
of diamonds today right not that I'm ins
that are cut today or better or worse
they're just different the cutting or
proportions are literally perfect
most of our diamonds were cut by hand
without electricity without computers a
lot of the facets which are the cuts are
not quite centered but they were cut
bigger because they were made to reflect
candle lights today my wife Kim is gonna
be helping you guys out looking at some
rings this ring it's called Eden cliff
so it dates back to about 1890 or so
it's 18 karat yellow gold which is very
very common at that time this has the
quintessential split shank here where it
supports the head of the ring and then
the top is a cluster kind of original
halo of look but this was likely an
earring once upon a time it's very flat
on the bottom but there's no curvature
for your finger but the entire head is
all original old mine cuts it's a really
special ring honestly I wouldn't even be
able to tell this ring with a hundred
years old
like I
feel like this is the ring goodbye today
hundred and twenty nine years old 120
the math 129 years old
you know what diamonds outside right
yeah okay it's like one diamond with all
our buddies trunks on oh wow the size of
my knuckle
maybe it's very big it's like you could
tell me I'm engaged to see and I'm
feeling yeah the ocean definitely bought
yes yes we'll just hold it there now
bring this tube to you whoa you couldn't
get it oh how one more ring I want to
show you this is also from the Victorian
era that has a sapphire Center still hot
no top and it's 18 karat rose gold one
advantage here is that there are lots of
different ways to accommodate both your
personal taste yeah as well as your
budget it gives you a really easy way to
tell a story - mmm it's very light
effort for the amount of romantic punch
you get oh thank your book okay yeah got
it
I feel like we really got into it at
trumpet noise yeah yeah you know what I
I will say I was a little nervous than
when I was there we all could tell no I
mean maybe it won't show through the
video probably will yeah you know what
it is I think with engagement is just
like an abundance of options kind of
like we're a restaurant with too many
options and you think you can't go back
to the restaurant again
yes it'll be a chance one shot to do the
restaurant and each item cause like
$6,000 in catering fact Octavio ginn and
Adriana Martinez hold the record for the
longest engagement in the world
oh they were waiting to be married for
67 years and they finally did it in 1969
in Mexico City they were 82 years old
Wow okay her parents will spit on her
let's say by ticking three if you like
alrighty
it's our final destination our final
destination this is where the prices go
up or we find out what is luxury like hi
I'm Sam sarkeesian I'm Jennifer
sarkeesian and today we're at a deal
more so y'all make custom ring do you
mostly sell your website correct a
majority of our business is online when
a customer places an order we actually
build the ring from scratch we put the
ring in a computer-aided design model
and put the Diamonds measurements the
customers finger size and what you get
basically a wax model of the end product
the bad bottle is then put into a flask
vacant overnight in the morning we
actually pour the gold into the flask
the quenching process basically removes
all the investment and what you have
left is the gold treat we do the pre
polish the diamond setting final quality
control then we ship it out to our
customers and give them a 30 day money
back guarantee all of our diamonds are
GI a certified yay is the most reputable
reading laboratory in the world a
difference in color can be two thousand
dollars or twenty five thousand dollars
it'll show you the certificate number
that number is actually etched onto the
diamonds and it's the diamonds
fingerprint the ring that will incident
what ring is them it is a rose gold
three carat D and buy one diamond it's
beautiful this one's between 55 and
60,000 okay so here we are it's time a
DM or a day look here we have it okay oh
honey why are fect I love it thank you
so much how the show works by the way
this I mean oh wow sorry I just take a
look at it from the side profile and
she's she's a she's a big beautiful hunk
of love it's also like what's nice about
it is that it's not like too
over-the-top but like holy bananas Wow
okay the thing that was really I don't
want to use this word lightly but
stunning when I when he poured it out
was the diamond that the law around it
it's the backup dancers
like in LA the backup dancers the big
diamond just the Beyonce gosh yeah okay
I want to examine the side diamonds
first yep those are done oh yeah that's
the big diamond this is Wow
so this is we've learned is I clean
which means like if I look at it here
and I'm just giving the eye test I don't
see yeah there's nothing I can't see
anything wrong with it it's spotless to
the naked eye now let me check it with
the magnification I can see some very
subtle inclusions here's a thing though
no one's looking at your ring back close
if somebody is popping this out next to
your hand that's order you just whack
them okay so I'm gonna ask you now
Kristen you only have one choice which
engagement ring was the most worth it to
you and it's given friend I think that
both ocher objects and idea more were
awesome and I think that like all of
them are worth that all of you ladies
are beautiful but one of you is the most
beautiful in my heart
I think trumpet and harness looks wha
you know I got my ring from there so it
seems like it the obvious choice for me
but having a ring that doesn't have a
single sibling in the world is worth it
to me what did you think was most worth
it with a deal more it was a lot of
money it was a lot of fun but my work
that winner goes to okhla Aldridge oh I
really really appreciated seeing that
side of engagement I always had this
thought in my head
you gotta spend this much money it's got
to be this shiny that doesn't really
matter as much as the love that you
share with the other person that has
been if for worth of lifestyle seasons
for thank you to all the people involved
in making the show in front of and
behind the camera all people who let us
film there and we will see you this time
on worth it
food Season six baby Wow that's right
oh my god an announcement and I was here
for any over here exclusive
[Music]